[Music]
good morning everyone we're about to
start this morning's program so if you
can make it to your seats it would be
greatly appreciated thank you
[Music]
we magnify the
yes your holiness
[Music]
hi
[Applause]
[Music]
I
hi
[Music]
[Applause]
good morning my name is Sandra Quinlan
I'm a senior pursuing a degree in
mechanical engineering and I'll be your
mistress of ceremonies for this
morning's breakfast celebration please
join me in thanking the MIT gospel choir
in the spirit of our celebration of the
life and legacy of dr. King we would
like you to greet me shake hands to
someone near you across from you behind
you or at your table
welcome to the 31st annual dr. Martin
Luther King jr. celebration I would like
to take this time to thank president
Susan Hockfield and her husband dr.
Thomas Byrne for hosting this event I'd
also like to welcome miss Gwen Ifill
it's a pleasure to have you here with us
this morning
as a current student I like to thank my
colleagues for waking up so early this
morning and making it over to welcome
amore o however we can't go on with this
morning's program without giving
recognition and thanks to the 2004-2005
Martin through King junior planning
committee to whom we owe this wonderful
morning as I call your names please
saying however please hold all applause
until all the names are called assistant
professor Larry Anderson Professor
Martin Culpepper please remain standing
professor John Dame on show professor
Jerome Friedman associate dean Arnold
Henderson junior assistant director
Deborah liver Minh co-director Paul
Pavano administrator Toby whiner
Reverend John Visnjic Chancellor Philip
L clay ex-officio sour right ex-officio
and Gregory Jones class of 2005 and the
committee co-chairs are Dean Leo Osgood
jr. and professor Michael Feld thank you
all for contributing to the success of
this event
this morning's program will begin with
an invocation from Reverend John West
Nick following the invocation we will
have breakfast after which to students
in Sara Gonzales class of 2007 and mr.
Jonathan Gabe's class of 2006
will guide us in reflection of the life
and legacy of dr. King Chancellor Philip
L clay will recognize the 2004-2005
Martin Luther King junior Leadership
Award ease we will then have the MIT
gospel choir come up to sing a selection
for us after which we'll hear remarks
from dr. Susan Hockfield and she will
introduce our keynote speaker miss Gwen
Ifill following the keynote speaker
Provost Robert Brown will recognize our
Martin Luther King jr. visiting
professors for the 2004-2005 academic
year
now listen begin breakfast with
invocation by Reverend John Visnjic good
morning everyone please join me in
prayer Almighty God as dawn breaks this
day we gather to celebrate the legacy
and work of dr. Martin Luther King jr.
warm our bodies from the cold outside
dispel from our hearts the fear within
enable us all to fully enjoy like
spirits people around us strangers
acquaintances and friends dedicated to
uphold the justice and equality which
are the rights of every human being and
where there is sadness because of
circumstance or condition hold this
sadness in your arms oh god help us all
to choose justice over greed help us to
choose freedom in lieu of self-interest
and accept the consequences
bless O Lord the food we will enjoy lift
up those who prepared this setting who
cooked the via the food and those who
clean and serve amen
things what ladies and gentlemen I hope
you've enjoyed your breakfast we will
now continue with the rest of our
program I have the pleasure of
introducing two of our very own students
Sara Gonzales a sophomore in the School
of Management and Jonathan Gabe's a
junior in aeronautics and astronautics
they will guide us in a reflection on
the life of legacy of dr. King we will
begin with Sara good morning welcome
president Hockfield distinguished
faculty and guests my name is Sara
Gonzales and I am a sophomore studying
management science and biomedical
engineering here at MIT this speech is
dedicated to all the positive role
models in my life in particular my
father who is celebrating his 50th
birthday today this morning I will talk
about the life and legacy of the great
dr. Martin Luther King jr. as an
educated man with a passion for the
podium dr. King spoke of brotherhood
equality and human rights he turned his
back on centuries of hatred and war he
embraced peaceful and unified protests
he suffered but persevere
in the end dr. King conquered an entire
country without ever picking up a weapon
he won an invaluable battle which was a
turning point in the fight for civil
rights however he did not win the war
we need to continue what he could not
overcome and overcome the stereotypes
and complacency that are hindering us
from fulfilling his dream rather than a
forced and demeaning separation my
generation grew up with an unspoken
social segregation a segregation caused
by people discouraging other people it
is not cool to be different
to cross boundaries to make straight A's
the youth of this generation and more
specifically a good number of the
minority population are not taking
advantage of the rights that dr. King
himself and many others fought for
including the right to move up in the
world socially academically politically
and professionally for example most
minorities in my hometown of Summerville
South Carolina have grown up with a
common but naive opinion that they can
never be professionals our scholars
because one there are so few positive
role models and secondly the
discouraging environment fails to
nurture achievement as the first person
from my high school and it's almost two
centuries of existence
to accepted to MIT I hid my joint
excitement because I was afraid of
disheartening comments my classmates
told me I was only accepted because I am
female and Latina even my favorite
teacher a female and the only teacher of
my high school with a doctorate degree
pulled me aside to discourage me from
attending MIT she told me that I would
not do well in the schools the Manion
environment and suggested I go somewhere
else
closer to home with less pressure at
that moment I believed her and I walked
away doubting myself more than ever
why would she be so discouraging why did
she not believe in me and encouraged me
to be the best as you can see I did not
allow her words to stop me from coming
here and standing before you this
morning
what she did not know is that I already
had a community of positive role models
in my life that encouraged me to step up
to the challenge of MIT I developed this
family during an intense 6-week program
called minority introduction to
engineering entrepreneurship and science
also known as Mike
every summer that program began brings
together the best of the best to push
them to their limits and show them what
they are capable of academically more
important however is the fostering
encouraging environment of entire of
determined minority students and high
achieving minority teaching assistants
the meit's program showed me that I am
not bound by any of the stereotypical
limitations associated with minority
ethnic groups nevertheless most minority
students not have the opportunity to
attend such an influential program how
will these students be able to stand up
against the many obstacles and racial
prejudices they will face throughout
their life how will they know that their
achievements are not limited by the
color of their skin
how will the youth of America be
encouraged to reach for the stars unless
they know about more role models such as
the first female president and mi team
dr. Susan Hockfield our planet
or prominent minority figures in the
White House including Kondylis Lisa rice
and Alberto Gonzalez just as dr. Martin
Luther King jr. influenced people to
reject inhumane treatment and demand
their rights despite the difficulties
they would face I hope that everyone in
this hall will reach out and embrace
every opportunity to mentor to become a
role model and to support programs that
encourage students to accept the
challenge and break through the
remaining frontiers professionally and
scholarly helped finish the war that dr.
King began thank you
Thank You Sara we will now hear from
Jonathan gabe's Jonathan good morning
again welcome my name is Jonathan Gibbs
and I'm a junior in aerospace
engineering
[Applause]
those that know me well will tell you
that I am no less than a fanatic about
the field of flying hence this fly blue
suit and currently I'm also the
treasurer of the MIT chapter of the
American Institute of Aeronautics and
Astronautics the Black Student Union
political action committee chair and a
Jackie Robinson scholar but more
importantly I am particularly proud to
be one of the many privileged products
at the preliminary progress that we are
here to celebrate my senses and spirits
are soaring in the stratosphere right
now because my retinas are the rich
recipients of a fantastic florescent
formation a fabulous flotilla
full of fervent and unique individuals a
fecund fleet of philanthropy Homo
sapiens who are not only the harvest but
also the cultivators of dr. King's
prolific premonition so on this morning
I am much obliged to dr. Martin Luther
King and to the many others who when
presented with America's moral dilemma
enlisted their lives into an armada for
justice in equality Thank You president
Hockfield for hosting this breakfast to
honor their legacy and I'm personally
grateful for the privilege of delivering
these remarks the other day I was in the
Mara I eaten lunch on my way to the
coupe to pick up some books and I sat
down one of those large couches and
begins to read the paper I peered up and
I saw a tall man I saw a homeless man
with a three-piece suit on and he looked
weary and cold and he came in sat down
across from me I asked him how he was
doing and he said he was in good spirit
even though he had a pain in the side I
saw a suitor had a small hole on the
left near the hip and he asked me for a
little bit of change and I gave him the
15 since I had in my pocket and he
remarked that he had enough spare change
and I was wondering why he would refuse
my generosity why would you bite the
hand that feeds you he said John don't
you look at me like that I'm your family
my name is dr. King and I was perfected
I was perplexed at the fact that this
homeless man knew my name
so I began a brief fireside chat with
him he said that people seemed to have
some sort of a dilemma we want to help
somebody but we don't want to risk our
own good fortune to do it but you had a
dilemma you gave me your spare change
because it's insignificant you won't
notice later that it's gone that way you
can feel humble and keep your money at
the same time that's interesting I said
and he wouldn't honor I became more and
more fascinated with his ideas and I
asked him where he was going
well John he said things are rotten in
Washington DC
did you know that senator light still
believes in the Hamitic hypothesis I'm
not surprised I said
and dr. King continued I was sending a
lot I knew dr. Mordecai Johnson dr.
Hargobind Carano dr. David Howe dr.
McCarroll Jamison or Henry Cisneros I
wish he knew about your brothers in
chocolate city
Gary Chris Charles Jonathan
Jonnie Brian and Calvin and it's not
just senator Lott oh really I said he
said yes he replied I just talked with
lawrence summers the president of Harvey
CCC he believed that women don't have
the same aptitude as men and I reminded
him of doctor of Harvard's own doctor
Cecilia Payne and I told them that just
down Mass Ave they have a president that
also proved and will continue to prove
his theory wrong
and mr. summers he talked about some of
it might use policies and programs and
he orated I kind of see MIT as it's kind
of an outcast it's not quite like other
schools I respectfully disagree mr.
Simmons became more arrogant agitated in
an irate so I provided some antiseptic
to alleviate his ignorance I told him
about dr. Nancy Leveson dr. Shirley Ann
Jackson dr. Nancy Hopkins and dr. sheila
widnall affirmed that while MIT may now
be the outcast you'll soon discover that
MIT is the prototype I said well dr.
King no wonder all of a sudden Lawrence
Summers made an initiative to hire more
female faculty and dr. King he started
leaning back in his chair and then he
said I came here to check up on you John
before I get on my way you see I saw you
in that private school in the DC
metropolitan area I saw you when you
almost flunked out because your appears
convince you that you were inferior and
I saw that teacher tell you that you
were not smart enough to continue that
they're predominantly white high school
and I saw you get ridiculed after your
acceptance to MIT and then I saw you eat
your last supper right here in the
Cambridge Marriott before you went on
down to Ames Street for your first day
of Project interphase I knew you was
accepted to other schools but you chose
to come to MIT and then despite your
accomplishments neither you nor your
appearance or sure you can make it at
the - yeah I remember I said it was the
best of times in the worst of times I
was happy to be here but I still I still
wasn't sure if that Hamitic hypothesis
was wrong I felt the weight of the world
on my shoulders and my knees buckling
and dr. King continued it some more time
passed and I observed the interphase was
the first time that you John were in a
positive academic environment and I
didn't have any more worries and I also
went to see your parents
and I asked about you they said Jonathan
did alright and he came home right after
interphase and they said they a few days
at a few days later they put you back on
a Southwest 737 with service to
Providence and that you never looked
back I said that's right I remember
touching down on runway five right I'd
see a green airport and dr. King
continued you know your mother wishes
you would call home more often and your
father said never to forget your
Christian upbringing and dr. King told
me he was glad to see that I was indeed
doing all right
he said I'm gonna tell you why
I got so mad about your spare change I
don't want your spare change because I
need to get all the way back to DC to
talk to senator life and if I had a
million dollars I could buy my own 737
and fly on down the national airport if
I had 50,000 I could make it
I can make a down payment on a BMW and
drive on down the turnpike and hey if I
had 1,000 I could buy that loop do you
call your minivan I said doctor kind of
whom do you buy lights let anybody else
drive it all I could mess up my mirrors
and stuff
and dr. King he went on well if I had a
hundred I could at least get a bicycle
from the new house bike auction but if
all you give me a spare change I have to
walk and stumble along with all
deliberate speed I have to be extra
extra extra careful because I don't want
to make a wrong step if you give me
spare change I'll always have to keep
asking for more spare change
and then you will ignore me I got enough
spare change to buy this suit and sit
here with you so I can look like you're
economical equal but you and I both know
that I'm homeless and when you gave me
your spare change you reinforced my
feelings of inferior
can you understand how insulting it is
when it is I that throws some spare
change at you
you can't even decide whether or not to
pick it up especially when all your
peers are watching you I hope you
understand why I don't want your spare
change
and as we concluded I told dr. King I
would drive to the airport and he asked
me if I would pass his message on to
somebody if I ever got the chance and
I'm glad I got the chance to pass that
message on to you today and later I went
home and I watched some TV I was
watching this movie and these two men
were trying to get rid of there's a
beaver dam because it was it was
blocking up a reservoir eventually one
of the men arrived with a shotgun and he
was about to shoot the family of beavers
and then before he can get a shot of one
of the Beavers ran up and he bit his
foot and the man dropped the shotgun
into the water while the beavers ran off
to safety you see even the beaver even
the beaver had enough courage to bite
the foot or the man with the gun trying
to shoot his family he knew he couldn't
move with all deliberate speed otherwise
he would have gotten shot sometimes I
wonder if we are just engineers or we
are actually beavers I know I'm a beaver
I got this ring on my finger right here
that says I'm a beaver and I always give
more than my spare change and don't
forget that it's taking over 100 years
of legislation sweat seriously the
citizens for us to sit here in an
academic setting to imbue our brains
each other's intellectual expeditions
but there is still much more work to be
done see maybe you didn't know somebody
that walked on Washington and maybe you
weren't related to anybody they had to
struggle for everything they had but
some of the people around you did and
they're from all different kinds of
places see the people that you work with
and bar with they're not just your
colleagues but they are your family oh
you may not be part of their immediate
family but if you open up
you will discover that you were a fact
of the same kingdom phylum in class and
if you read on a little bit further you
will you'll discover that we are all in
fact the same family and if we like in
ourselves to beavers we ought to act
like beavers and move to protect our
family
let's all join dr. king's our might on
the way to DC but before we do that we
have to understand how ridiculous
insulting and foolish it is that trying
to accomplish dr. king's go with just
spare change
but we need to comprehend the reason
that the reason why we have to stumble
along with all deliberate speed because
we have to keep asking for more spare
change I hope we understand why nobody
cares about spare change and I know you
don't want my spare change thank you
[Applause]
Thank You Jonathan once again I would
like to thank well Sara Gonzales and
Jonathan Gibbs for letting the words of
dr. King be heard once more I hope that
everyone here today had a chance to
listen carefully now I have the honor of
asking Chancellor Philip LA to come to
the podium and recognize the MLK 2005
leadership Ortiz
Chancellor K Sarah and Jonathan were
wonderful and I think we need a song to
move the program along but I'm afraid
you have me I want to take just a minute
to recognize the this year's winners of
the dr. Martin Luther King Leadership
Awards these awards have been given for
a number of years to individuals in our
community faculty students alumni staff
who have given extra we might call it
those who have stepped up in some way
and we have the honor of recognizing
three people who are exemplars of that
tradition this morning but if I could
just say an additional word as Jonathan
was speaking I thought back on a speech
that dr. King gave that spoke to the
issue of stepping out and both of our
student speakers appointed to the
discouraging experiences that they had
and our examples of a willingness to
step out on the wings of faith and dr.
King talked about this flight he was on
where the storm was was very violent
there was the need to move
on from the particular city and how at
some point the pilot said we are going
to step out on wings of faith as it were
and we have a case here of individual
students who did that stepping out on
the wings of faith and it's to the
credit of the mites program and
interphase and other initiatives that
they were able to do that and I hope we
can maintain that opportunity to make
sure that there are these wings that
provide a path for our student leaders
the three people who are honored this
year are first mr. James s banks class
of 76 James
James is an executive with
hewlett-packard and the Agilent
Technologies and over a number of years
has worked with our offices of minority
education to identify job opportunities
and industrial support for mites and
other programs and we're grateful to
James for this not only in his role as
an alum but as a graduate of MIT and the
mites program thank you very much our
second awardee is Russell you that we
all know him as Eric Caulfield graduate
student
erica is the immediate past president of
the Graduate Student Council and all of
us sure are aware of his excellent
leadership during the critical period of
when the Institute under his leadership
of graduate students the Institute was
able to make progress in a number of
areas including health insurance and
housing and I mentioned to Eric last
night or to the dinner last night that
Eric probably gave more homework to
those of us in the administration and
any student in recent time I don't think
he quite got that but I'm sure my
colleagues and the administration know
how much extra work Eric made us do and
we're all the better for it so thank you
very much Eric
our third awardee is Professor James
Shirley professor and bioengineering
in the nomination letters we had the
text of the nomination and there was a
very long list of students as well as
colleagues who pointed to the great
leadership James is given in the area of
student mentoring and science and
leadership and support for a number of
student organizations we are delighted
when faculty members take these make
this extra effort to support students
both in their classroom and their
scholarship and in their organizations
so for these things we thank and honor
professor Shirley
last night we had a dinner at which
these awards were made and we gave them
a nice plaque and something in an
envelope I never opened the envelope
thank you very much thank you very much
and congratulations to this year's
recipients / Chancellor clays request I
would like to invite the MIT gospel
choir up to the stage for another
selection
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you it gives me great pleasure to
welcome the 16th president of MIT and
the first female president in the
Institute's history dr. Susan Hockfield
she will give some remarks and proceed
to introduce today's guest speaker miss
Gwen Ifill president
[Applause]
morning everybody it's an enormous
thrill to be here and I want to thank
all of you for coming together this
morning in this fantastic celebration
not a day goes by since I began somewhat
less than two months ago and actually
started when after I was my appoint was
announced in August but that'll really
not a day has gone by when I have not
been astounded impressed inspired by MIT
students and this morning I just want to
thank thank Sarah and Jonathan again for
incredibly moving and deeply intelligent
comments so thank you both very very
much
so as a relative newcomer to the MIT
community I want to start by saying how
impressed I am that this is the
Institute's 31st annual celebration of
dr. King's life and legacy this is a
remarkably long-standing tradition and
like many of the things I found at MIT a
fantastic surprise and reflected a very
deep insight and very deep sensitivity
to the issues that matter in today's
world as we all go through our very busy
lives it's very easy to become
complacent and to neglect seemingly
intractable social and political issues
in favor of the more pressing and
immediate concerns today's event is one
important way that we can regularly
sharpen our focus on the dream of Martin
Luther King jr. this morning we are
particular thanks to Professor Michael
Feld and Dean Leo Osgood and their
colleagues on the organizing committee
for their work on this event because in
bringing the MIT community together each
year this breakfast asks us to renew our
commitment to the values dr. King
articulated and that he exemplified in
his own life and work this morning in
short reminds us that it is our
collective responsibility to meet the
need for a more just and a more
inclusive society of course no single
person or no single organization alone
can promote justice and equality
successfully by working in isolation
difficult social and political issues
require a spirit of collaboration and a
willingness to cooperate across
institutional boundaries so I'm
particularly pleased that we're joined
today by city councilor and former mayor
ken Reeves who has been and I commit to
being an ongoing partner in our work
whereas Ken
so this morning I would like to suggest
that MIT even though we cannot work in
isolation has a special responsibility
to meet the challenge of creating a more
diverse and more supportive community
that's not to say that any other
institution can feel free to abdicate
its moral responsibilities this is of
course an issue for every institution
and for every individual in our society
but MIT is different and every day I
find a new way in which MIT is different
and special and it's we are different
from other educational institutions in
ways that make these particular
questions that today brings focus to
especially salient for us here I want to
point to two things in particular first
the Institute has long served as a
tremendous engine of opportunity for
social achievement we have a long
history of educating students who have
not had the advantages of wealth and
status students who then have gone on to
change the world as leaders in science
and technology in business and in public
service if we are to keep that tradition
alive and we would hope to extend it
even further we cannot ignore any part
of our population we must recruit a
diverse student body opening MIT to
anyone who can benefit from the
tremendous opportunities that are
available here as I said when I met the
MIT community for the first time in
August and as I still believe and I am
sure I will continue to believe I want
MIT to be the dream of every child who
wants to make the world a better place
we must be equally open when it comes to
our faculty and staff America and the
world have benefited enormously from MIT
s willingness during after the Second
World War to hire teachers and scholars
from many nations and from groups that
have been denied full membership in a
restrictive Academy as we look to the
future we need to keep the lesson of
that history in mind this leads directly
to the second reason I think true
equality is so important for us MIT is
is a great meritocracy as I talked to
the members of the institute community
during the search process and the
transition period this core value the
great meritocracy came up again and
again people of the Institute feel can
feel passionately that this is one of
our core values and one of our greatest
strengths it's one of the things that
make them proudest about being part of
MIT and make me proud about having
joined this community but we cannot rest
on our laurels or on values that we both
say we believe we hold and assume that
we've gotten it right once and for all
as we evaluate people for possible
membership in the MIT community and
evaluate their performance once they're
here we need constantly to ask are we
really looking at merit social science
research is demonstrated very powerfully
how unconscious assumptions can affect
our judgement of people and their
performance if our aspiration is for MIT
to be the great meritocracy in America
and higher education and I believe it
can be we have to understand how to free
our judgments from unconscious
preconceptions we expect the best at MIT
but we have to make sure we can
recognize it it is essential that MIT is
and just as important is seen as a
welcoming and supportive place for
anyone from any background who has the
talent and passion to make the most of
what the Institute has to offer this is
what is right and is what our traditions
tell us to do and it will strengthen
education and research for everybody
here and for everybody around the world
I'm reminded of an anecdote from the
late 1960s when institutions like my
previous one began to admit women for
the first time there's a story from one
of the women who was you know among the
first at one of these Ivy League
universities remembers vividly when in
response to a question she asked in
class
her professor said to her with absolute
delight no one has ever asked me that
question before bringing new voices to
the table changes the conversation MIT
of all institutions must remember that
innovation comes we bring new
perspectives to bear on existing
problems by pointing to the challenges
we face I don't intend to slight the
great steps this institution has taken
to enhance and sustain the diversity of
its community our student body is
unusually diverse by the standards of
any of our peer institutions our faculty
and staff include exceptional
individuals from every possible
background and we have made tremendous
progress with respect to women's issues
but I suspect that you will agree with
me that there is still much more that
needs to be done in particular we have a
long way to go before we can be
satisfied that we have done all we can
to create a diverse graduate student
body and a diverse faculty nonetheless
as I look at the remarkable people
gathered here in this room this morning
I see great strength and great potential
and a very good place from which to
begin the next leg of our journey
together making progress on that journey
will require strong faculty
participation because as an educational
institution we are defined by our
faculty and I know that our faculty will
not let MIT down last May the faculty
made a public commitment to take a
leadership position among our peer
institutions in the recruitment and the
academic success of underrepresented
minority faculty and graduate students
and coming in after that resolution was
passed
I am enormous ly grateful to the faculty
for its leadership on this issue the
provost the Chancellor the deans and I
all look forward to working with the
faculty to take the steps necessary to
meet this goal now I beg your
forgiveness as I close with reflections
on a somewhat more personal note it is
truly a tremendous honor for me to stand
among you here this morning
the presidency of this unique
institution is a great privilege and
like any privilege it carries with it
tremendous responsibility as a woman I
know that I have benefited from the
pioneers who blazed the trail for the
women of my generation opening doors to
education and careers that had long been
closed as president of MIT I know that
one of my most important
responsibilities is to ensure that
others have the sort of opportunity that
has brought me here and I hope that in
the years ahead
we can all work together to bring dr.
King's dream to life thank you all very
much for joining us this morning
now it gives me great pleasure to
introduce the person who at least you
know I have been just excited to hear
from since I first learned that she was
going to be our guest at this morning's
this morning's event Gwen Ifill you all
know she is one of the most highly
respected journalists in Washington with
deep experience in both print and
broadcast media we all know this is not
an easy field and Gwen Ifill has climbed
the ladder to a position of
international renown deliberately and
successfully in ways that all of us can
admire she's been a reporter for a
number of major newspapers including the
New York Times and The Washington Post
and she served for five years as chief
congressional and political
correspondent for NBC News when she
covered politics for the NBC Nightly
News with Tom Brokaw the Today Show Meet
the Press and MSNBC today Gwen Ifill
holds two major positions in political
journalism she's a moderator and
managing editor of Washington week a
show we many of us have been watching
since we were children the
longest-running public affairs program
on public television and she is also
senior correspondent for the news hour
with Jim Lehrer one measure of Gwen
Ifill standing in her field is the she
is frequently asked to moderate debates
in national elections most recently we
had the pleasure of watching her in last
year's vice presidential debate she
serves on the board of Harvard
University's Institute of Politics and
the University of Maryland's Philip
Merrill College of Journalism and she
has received numerous honorary degrees
in recognition of her contributions to
political journalism Gwen Ifill grew up
in New York City and now lives in
Washington DC but she has close ties to
our area as well she's a graduate of
Simmons College in Boston and works as a
reporter for the Boston Herald we are
delighted that she is here with us in
Cambridge this morning when eiffels work
and experience gave her a unique vantage
point on American society and politics
so we look forward to hearing her
thoughts on the challenges facing us as
we seek to live up to the standards set
by dr. King please join me in giving our
warmest welcome to miss Eiffel as she
joins us at MIT
thank you thank you dr. Hockfield even
though we don't believe you've been
watching Washington week since you were
a child we'll just let that pass you're
younger than you look but not that young
thank you all for having me I learned a
lot of things already this morning
including that I should be referring to
this place as the toot I've never
thought of it that way but I'm very
happy to be at the toot part of my
continuing tour of college campuses
colleges which would have never admitted
me when I was applying for school in
fact I think when I think back on it the
closest I ever got to actually getting
inside MIT when I was when I was an
undergraduate at Simmons coming to black
student organization parties which is I
recall were kind of slamming at the time
we were still doing the bump then
and MIT men were pretty good at it I'll
just say but we'll move on returning to
college campuses always gives me an
opportunity to think back over how far
I've come my dancing has improved for
instance but it also gives me a chance
to experience what it's like to never
leave a place at all I may never have
actually attended MIT but I bet our
experiences are not really so different
I have been a black student on a
predominantly white college campus
trying to find my way like you I have
been a college student terrified that
the college degree that I was staying up
so many nights to study for trying to
earn may not get me the job that I
wanted to get and Lord knows I have
given and attended my share of Black
History Month Martin Luther King
speeches I've been at speeches where
they tell you about George Washington
Carver and the peanut I have been at
speeches where we are exhorted to keep
our hope alive I cover them in fact when
Jesse Jackson was running for president
and I still have the scars to show for
that one I shouted I am somebody even
before I was entirely sure who that
somebody was I have since figured that
part out I have sung we shall overcome
in that great getting up morning I've
been buked and I been scorned in gospel
choirs and I have sung the Negro
national anthem the black national hymn
whatever you want to call it countless
times in fact I learned to gauge the
sincerity of the politicians I was
covering over time especially when they
were in black churches making their
pitches by trying to decide whether they
knew all the verses
they'll Clinton knew all the verses it
should be sad
but the words god of our silent years
weary years god of our silent tears thou
who has brought us so far on the way
what can I say I'm a preacher's kid I
learned all the words to all the songs
but that's what I like about Black
History Month actually I like the memory
triggers the opportunity to remember and
revel in the things that we don't spend
enough time thinking about the rest of
the year
Black History Month only a month and a
short month of that it used to be Ashley
back history week as I recall it as that
when I was a child but I've always been
suspicious that they gave us the
shortest month of the year but you take
what you can get I mean it takes all 28
days to explain to the generations of
young people who were never alive when
Martin Luther King jr. was that he is
more than just a stamp or a distant icon
he symbolizes in many ways the ideals
that I strive to combine in my life my
life as a professional journalist and my
life as a black American attempting to
prosper in a society that often can seem
so hostile my father like every preacher
that I ever met growing up and who was
alive in the 60s marched with Martin
Luther King that was always the lion I
marched with Martin Luther King and he
taught me very important lessons about
what that meant he taught me that we had
responsibilities to our country to our
people and to our God he taught us that
if anyone ever heard Harold the word
black at us meaning it as it would meant
in the 60s and early 70s as an inverse
acceptable and black was not good and we
were shocked to discover as kids that a
simple thank you always shut up our
detractors that would be insult givers
were just reduced to silence by that and
that's before black was beautiful but as
preachers kids we had other challenges
to meet as well the expectations were
very high there is always someone
watching our behavior from a window we
were lucky in that way but I didn't
realize that until years later when I
saw the habit that can be reached that
can be reaped
among black people and black families by
low expectations
we heard some stories about that already
this morning it's always amazing to me
when theme is billed over its course of
a program
I suspect none of you would be here this
morning if it were not for the high
expectations that someone had of you
whether it was your parents whether it
was your larger community
guardians people who caught a glint a
little bit of a sign of your possibility
it is the striving for possibility that
fuel the ambitions of Harriet Tubman who
did the unthinkable by trying to get
slaves free and Sojourner Truth who did
the unthinkable by considering that
maybe women could be equal a people like
Martin Luther King who saw the
possibilities of how equal access and
simple justice could transform a nation
to people like my parents who saw how
they could apply the lessons they learn
from those who preceded them to make a
better life for their children because
of those who have gone before I remain
committed to the things these people and
more taught me were important it is
actually why I am a journalist and it is
how I came to believe that the search
for truth and the search for justice are
not incompatible in fact they are
essential if we are to stay true to the
hard-earned legacy left to us by Martin
Luther King jr. I believe that boy being
born an American of African heritage has
always been a challenge it's easy to
focus on the negatives but those
negatives and the positives that we
don't always focus on forces us to rise
to the goals of dr. King set for us it's
why when I was a college student working
at my first big summer job at a
newspaper right here in Boston I was
able to shrug off the insult of finding
a note one day waiting for me when I
arrived at work that said go home
it's why I was able to challenge the
editors at the newspaper I worked at in
Baltimore when they thoughtlessly
decided to use a feature picture on page
one of young black kids in the back of a
truck eating watermelon in 1981 it's why
I was able to moderate last year's vice
presidential debate and not forget the
uniqueness of my role in that
staged when I asked both men about the
rising incidence of the infection of HIV
infection among african-american women
sadly neither one of them had the ghost
of an answer but their silence spoke
volumes to people at home and imagine my
shock and surprise last night to hear
the president mention it in the State of
the Union speech says someone was paying
attention I don't get up every day
feeling burdened by race I feel
empowered by it and even if I didn't it
has been a constant throughout my career
I bet it's been a constant throughout
your lives as well when I started my
first job at the Herald American the
struggles over court-ordered school
busing were in full cry and I was thrust
straight from my ivy-covered bubble at
Simmons into a city newspaper where I
was forced to cover city riots by phone
because I wasn't going to Southie oh no
they weren't paying me enough
but also I worked in a newsroom it
should be said with a lot of at the time
really old-fashioned white guys with
starched white shirts and cigars who had
never seen anything like me before but
adapted the idea that it was possible
there was the possibility of excellence
and goodwill and good cheer in the face
of a young black woman when I moved to
Baltimore the Rachel climate was
distinctly different african-americans
had just gained the majority and I got
to cover what I learned to call tipping
point politics that's when the people
have always been in charge or gradually
painfully ceding control to the majority
it's happening in Iraq right now the
mayor and most of the City Council in
Baltimore was white but the city's black
majority was just beginning to feel its
clout and watching the process of
handing over power then and now has
always been fascinating to me by the
time I moved to Washington to work for
the Washington Post covering Prince
George's County which is in a suburban
suburban area right outside of
Washington that it was the same kind of
mirror image in that all of a sudden the
county was tipping and racing politics
and journalism were always becoming a
constant a light motif throughout my
life it's certainly not the only thing
I've covered but it has always somehow
managed and race and change and how we
handle that in this country has never
been far away from the essential debates
that we have in this country but to me
race and the discussion of race is not
always about grievance it is also about
opportunity and it's about pride and
empathy and humanity understanding the
value of difference it's why even though
I can maintain the journalists arm's
length distance that is required
I can also suffer genuine sorrow and
real rage over famine in Africa and
ethnic slaughter in Kosovo the death of
one man dragged behind a truck the
deaths of thousands on a beautiful
Tuesday morning in September or of
hundreds of thousands and a war-torn
province in Indonesia if I stopped
seeing the humanity in the news and
started seeing only the news that I
would be a failure as a journalist
and I would be a failure as a human
being I have the great good god-given
fortune of being able to sit on the
front row of history that's not
something I take lightly
because I don't believe for even a
minute that I got where I have gotten in
my career because of anything that I did
by myself my life has been divided into
the period why my expectations were set
for me by my parents and the time when I
began to set the expectations for myself
the first period with my parents you
have to understand they were West
Indians black people who chose to be
African Americans thank you
they taught me a lot of important things
about what it means to be a black woman
they taught me that America was a land
of opportunity but that the
opportunities are not going to just fall
in your lap because they ought to they
convinced me that I could do anything I
wanted to do so after years of treating
Black History Month as a little more
than an annual ritual I embrace it now
and I see those spaces in front of me
but I do part of the reason is that when
I give speeches like this I am given the
opportunity to talk about how I live and
what I live every day I live inside my
skin and I live outside of it like other
black professionals I keep a leaf put in
at least two worlds maybe three or four
one foot in the world of work most of my
colleagues bosses subordinates are white
probably always will be I don't think I
have to lose myself in order to function
in this world but there is no question
that I suppress a part of myself in
order to do that and I think we all do
that in different levels but I laugh
when people tell me you know I just want
you to know I'm colorblind
I mean isn't that funny when you think
about it cuz to me that just means that
they aren't entirely blind why shouldn't
why shouldn't they notice my color what
what color am I to them if they're a
color blind that's not a problem for me
I'm proud of being what I am it is
essential I just don't want to be held
back because of it
colorblindness and as we all know color
bloodless the blindest does that really
work
I mean cases it's the first thing people
see about you they want to know if they
see blond blue-eyed off she's black I
love it when people ask me I asked it
described so and so they say oh it's
about six feet tall
he's uh you know he's wearing a blue
suit and they tell me every other
distinguishing characteristic except his
race I'm like is he black oh yeah if you
asked Venus or Serena or tiger or maybe
not tiger but they'll tell you
that's the first thing people see and if
you ask me I certainly well I have my
other foot in this other world my many
black folks I know believe with total
certainly certainty that we all live in
a racist society one constructed in such
a way that we can never catch a break
every indignity they suffer adds to that
rage
I mean I've certainly experienced these
indignities to this day it is an open
question in whether I can get a cab in
downtown DC even if I'm wearing a suit
and carrying a briefcase on an average
day and before I went into television
actually I used to call people up to
interview them on the phone and then I
had this satisfaction of watching this
shock on their face this one they met me
for the first time you could tell they
were abiding back the exclamation but
you're doing the song block I miss being
able to do that I can't get away with it
anymore but every year when Black
History Month rolls around I get to give
talks like this and you get to hear them
and you get to hear about I have a dream
and Booker T Washington if you're lucky
w EBD boys but it only lasts a month and
it would all fade away if we didn't
invest more in the songs and in the
words than just our voices the words of
dr. King's I have a dream speech are
appealing to us as Americans of course
because dreaming is so much easier than
fighting but we have to dream and we
have to fight too
my parents taught me that they dreamed
their children would be able to do
anything they wanted and they knew we
had to fight to do it and even my father
who was an old-fashioned male chauvinist
neglected somehow to tell my sister and
me that there wasn't anything that we
could do how happy dr. King would be to
know that these days for so many of us a
tough part of the challenge is setting
priorities and making choices building
our careers living honourable lives
working hard to give our children all
the choices they deserve how sad he
would be to know that for so many of us
those choices are still out of reach but
it's that last choice that I mentioned
working hard for our children that's the
one that keeps us up at night we don't
want to knock down walls and break
through glass ceilings only to discover
our sons and daughters don't want to
walk through the doors they don't want
to soar to the next level and so many of
our sons and daughters are
by into these limits that are imposed by
race or they feel are no matter what
race they happened to be I've listened
to white friends talk cautiously about
their race grievances and I've listened
to black friends talk about theirs and
everyone has a point everyone has a
story like mine to tell but if we don't
get past these grievances we will never
meet our expectations not our parents
and not our own one of my great concerns
that we don't devote enough time these
days to thinking seriously as citizens
there seems to be less reward for
issuing a challenge that takes you out
of the mainstream more we were for
telling people what they want to hear
but I did not fear for the Republic just
yet that's because occasionally
something breaks through that reminds me
that across America
folks in the red and blue states however
you want to look at it are actually
still having conversations with one
another talking about their lives not
about it Ebonics but about education not
about OJ search for the real killer or
Michael Jackson's trial of the century
but about crime and criminal justice and
whether it's being applied equally not
about preconceptions but about the
limitations and expectations of race I
once got a letter from a woman who saw
me on Meet the Press we had done a
program about the Million Man March and
she was moved to write me and she
described herself in her letter as a
white middle-aged housewife who
experienced culture shock when she was
first exposed to discrimination based on
race she wrote at Jeff that she
generally finds it hard to believe that
racism is as widespread and spread now
as she is generally led to believe from
watching television news she said quote
we all have our own truths but some
truths are universal and it is upon
those that we must all strive to find
common ground and try to overcome the
differences rather than constantly
condemning our entire society is
basically degenerate and evil I like the
tone of this letter that maybe that's
because so many of the emails I get her
soul it much less literate
this letter was reasonable and it was
hopeful she didn't necessarily believe
that racism exists but she does think
there must be way for all us all to get
past it in whatever it is for us to get
along but how do we get there
how do we get past our preconceptions
our need your defensive Nisour we can
recapture those expectations it seems
appropriate this morning especially for
us to turn to the words of dr. King for
expectation but I'm not gonna read to
you from the I have a dream speech you
probably hear that one a lot this month
I said I'm going to read to you from a
piece of dr. King's work which actually
is excerpted on the cover of your
programs I was happy to see it rocked me
the first time I read it and has every
time since it's from his letter from a
Birmingham jail written in 1963 on
scraps of paper borrowed from his jailer
as well behind bars it's brilliance lies
in words that can be applied to almost
every situation he was writing about
race but listen to the words he was
speaking to anyone who ever had an
uphill battle to fight these are his
words for years now I have heard the
word wait it rings in the ear of every
Negro with piercing familiarity this
wait has almost always meant never we
must come to see with one of our
distinguished jurists that justice too
long delayed is justice denied we have
waited for more than 340 years for our
constitutional and god-given rights the
nations of Asia and Africa are moving
with jet-like speed toward gaining
political independence but we still
creep at horse and buggy pace toward
gaining a cup of coffee at a lunch
counter perhaps it was easy for those
who have never felt the stinging darts
of segregation to say wait but when you
have seen vicious mobs lynch your
mothers and fathers at will and drown
your sisters and brothers at whim when
you have seen hate-filled policemen
curse kick and even kill your black
brothers and sisters when you see the
vast majority of your twenty million
Negro brothers smothering in an airtight
cage of society poverty in the midst of
an affluent society when you suddenly
find your
tongue-twisted in your speech stammering
as you seek to explain to your
six-year-old daughter why she can't go
to the amusement park that has just been
advertised on television and see tears
welling up in her eyes when she is told
that fun town is closed to coggle
colored children and see ominous clouds
of inferiority beginning to form in her
little mental sky and see her beginning
to distort her personality by developing
an unconscious bitterness toward white
people when you have to concoct an
answer for a five-year-old son who was
asking daddy why do white people treat
colored people so mean when you take a
cross-country drive and find it
necessary to sleep night after night in
the uncomfortable corners of your
automobile because no motel will accept
you when you are humiliated day in and
day out by nagging signs reading white
and colored when your first name becomes
and your middle name becomes boy
however old you are and your last name
becomes John and your white and mother
are never given the respected title and
mrs. when you are harried by day and
haunted by night by the fact that you
are a Negro living constantly on tiptoe
stance never quite knowing what to
expect next and are plagued by inner
fears and outer resentments when you are
ever fighting a degenerating sense of
nobody Ness
then you will understand why we find it
so difficult to wait it comes a time
when the cup of endurance runs over and
men are no longer willing to be plunged
into the abyss of despair it is easy to
forget 40 yearly 40 years later how
stark the choices were at that time how
limited their horizons could be so many
students at all of our nation's colleges
now were boring long after Martin Luther
King was dead and they understand it
only in the abstract now of course you
might say things are different we can go
to the amusement park if we want to we
can eat at any lunch corner we want
there are so many things that we no
longer have to wait for but that if
that's all you hear in dr. King's words
you are missing the point
he is making the case for expectation
we should expect to be treated as equal
citizens our children should not expect
to be inferior we should all expect that
anything is achievable if not now then
soon I got into journalism because I
thought that at some level that I could
change the world that I could shine some
light into dark corners that I could
break down a few barriers the barriers
are still there the corners are still
dark sometimes and I've discovered the
world as often still resistant to change
but shining that light with the
flashlight that dr. King gave us that
light of justice the light of
understanding into the world that can be
tremendously satisfying I wish for you
that satisfaction thank you very much
for having me
[Applause]
everyone please join me once again and
thanking miss Gwen Ifill for her
heartfelt world thank you I would now
like to ask Provost Robert a brown to
recognize the 2004-2005 Martin Luther
King visitor professors as you might
notice there's attrition occurring in
our ranks for those of you who don't
spend many hours in our community you'll
know that teaching really begins at 10
there are some 9 o'clock classes but not
many it's a pleasure to have a few
moments to describe the Martin Luther
King jr. visiting professor program it
was founded in 1995 at MIT to bring
outstanding black and Hispanic scholars
to our community to enrich the diversity
of the academic staff the program has
sponsored visiting faculty across the
five schools at the Institute with
candidates nominated by the faculty and
then join their departments during their
stay here the candidates participate in
teaching and research in interacting
with the faculty with undergraduate and
graduate students essentially this
morning we have 5 MLK visiting
professors and scholars that were with
us some of them have gone off to
practice their honorable profession I
will introduce each one and I'll ask the
the two that remain to stand first is
professor Daniel Byrd professor Burt is
an MLK visiting assistant professor in
the Sloan School of Management visiting
from Stanford University he received his
BS in chemical engineering from
Northwestern and his master's and PhD in
business administration and philosophy
from Harvard professor Byrd's research
interests include learning implications
of inner
organizational structures and
competitive interaction networks in
knowledge flows he just left to teach
his class second is dr. Aleta Jones dr.
Jacque Lisa will you please stand thank
you dr. Jones is a visiting scholar in
the department of urban studies and
planning and will join the faculty of
the department of public administration
and policy at SUNY Albany at the in
diverse stay here she received her BA in
urban studies at Columbia in 1991 in a
PhD from Yale in political science her
dissertation examined how informal
immigration banking policies are
politicized by community banking
movements
she's a recipient of numerous award in
one of the most interesting things is
prior to attending Yale she held the
choral fellowship in public affairs and
worked on transportation health and
housing policy for the city of New York
New York City Council Aleta welcome
actually an old friend of MIT professor
Anthony Joseph who also just left to
teach is with us professor Joseph is a
visiting in the computer science in AI
laboratory csail in the Department of
Electrical Engineering of computer
science he's come back to MIT he
received his BS and SM degrees from EECS
and his PhD in computer science from MIT
after leaving MIT he joined the
University of California Berkeley
faculty and has been teaching there
since he's received numerous honors
including a Nokia visiting research
fellowship a National Science Foundation
Career Award in an IBM corporate
graduate fellowship dr. Anthony will be
with us for the year next is Professor
Kofi mag Lowe please stand
[Applause]
professor maglev is visiting in the
Department of linguistics and philosophy
from the University of Cincinnati he
received two bas one in philosophy and
the other in education from the
University of Benin and Togo as well as
to MAS one in philosophy and the other
in education from the University of
Burgundy France he also received a PhD
in philosophy from the University of
Burgundy his areas of specialization
include contemporary philosophy of
science the history of modern physics
Newton science and Newtonian mechanics
in the history of modern philosophy and
metaphysics he's teaching a class in the
philosophy of science this term correct
welcome
and and finally is miss Patricia Powell
Patricia is visiting in the program in
writing in humanistic studies at MIT she
received her MFA from Brown University
in creative writing and fiction and her
BA from Wellesley College in Boston Miss
Powell is a distinguished fiction writer
of fiction she is the author of three
widely reviewed novels numerous short
pieces and is currently finishing her
fourth novel at MIT she's an experienced
teacher and has worked extensively with
students on creative writing at Harvard
University and at the University of
Massachusetts before coming to MIT her
focus is on Caribbean American culture
and this is adding an unique element of
multicolor unique element to our writing
program during her stay Patricia
couldn't be with us today would we
please welcome again all these five
distinguished people
[Applause]
we will now have the MIT gospel choir
lead us in singing the black national
anthem lift every voice and sing by
James Weldon Johnson we ask that you
join and sing with the choir we won't
judge if you don't know the lyrics cuz
luckily they're on the back of your
programs this morning and please stand
as a song a son thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
now would like to invite City Councilman
Reeves to the stage
good morning everyone
you know I I've never seen that
breakfast so it's good to see who comes
to breakfast and this was a breakfast I
had to attend because all of my
inspirations are here this morning you
missed her but this novelist patricia
powell is brilliant and I'm now reading
her book a gathering of small bones
she's a Jamaican and I'm a Jamaican and
I'm really excited that you have her
here so Bravo MIT president Hockfield
you have hit the ground running and
you'll do very well and the city and the
citizens are very very happy happy happy
to have you amongst us I want to thank
you and Gwen Ifill for assuring us that
our mission here this morning is to
change the world and make it a better
place to live I like you Glenn and
attended my share of the I have a dream
breakfast and you have managed to break
out of the box of the speeches so it was
magnificent and and in inspiring I leave
you with two quick thoughts and then I
have a little presentation
you know this holiday means nothing if
the world isn't made a better place and
today there are two people in this room
who are doing that you know we leave
this breakfast to an America where 50%
of the black men in major urban centers
are unemployed and 1/3 of black gay men
in major urban centers are hiv-positive
so if you don't think there are
challenges for us to meet outside ponder
those two statistics a lot with me this
morning is a magnificent friend of mine
from Los Angeles he is America's
foremost african-american AIDS activist
I would like you to say hello
- Phil Wilson from Los Angeles
[Applause]
now when all this is really about you so
could you please come up I have had the
great pleasure Gwen Ifill spur has had
some cambridge time when I was a few
years younger she was a member with me
at Saint Paul AME Church and and I have
watched her career and I must say you
make the news real for me and unless you
say it I don't believe when you were no
longer with when you were no Margaret
NBC in the White House I didn't believe
anybody else you have brought
intelligence integrity excitement truth
to the news so you go girl and know that
we are out there when whenever your face
is on the camera and I'm in the house
and TV is on I'm glued to it because you
are my representative in the middle of
the fray making sure that truth and
power are connected and I could not be
more pleased and I would get up and come
to breakfast with you
[Laughter]
you know I get so tired sometimes of
reflecting on Martin Luther King's dream
but I must say that you are evidence of
the fruition of a part of that dream so
thank you for being there I offer you
the city's proclamation welcoming you
and in addition when we have special
esteemed you now you say you're West
Indian which Indian which island are you
Barbados
[Applause]
[Laughter]
this is an internal joke I'm not going
the barb agents have the highest
literacy in the world
98% blissful you see on behalf of the
people of Cambridge in this People's
Republic I'll give you the key to the
city and our hearts and we have lots of
our babies
we will now continue with some
announcements relevant to today's
celebration I would like to announce
that the Martin Luther King committee
presents the dr. Martin Luther King
installation located in Lobby 10
designed and constructed by the Darton
Martin Luther King jr. IEP seminar
please make sure if you haven't seen it
already that you stopped by Lobby
tenancy it's very informative and
inspirational they also produce the
booklets of information that all of you
have on your seats and this was
dedicated to commemorate the life and
legacy of dr. Martin Luther King jr. now
I would like to ask Reverend Amy Makris
to come forward to give the benediction
to close this morning's program good
morning the word benediction means
blessing and I think you'll agree with
me that we've already been blessed many
times over this morning so let me offer
a final benediction to end this time
together would you please rise
live without fear your Creator loves you
and has called and empowered you to do
justice to make peace and to transform
this world let us go forth from this
place with courage with hope and with
great resolve and most importantly with
joy let the people say amen amen